[Music]
welcome to the science podcast for March
15th 2019 I'm Sara Krusty in this week's
show I talk with staff writer Daniel
Clary about the many many theories
surrounding fast radio bursts these are
extremely fast intense radio signals
from outside our galaxy and a new
telescope that's coming online that
might help sort out some of these ideas
and I talked with staff writer Jennifer
cousin Franco about her story on the
long-term effects of pediatric cancer
treatment
the survival rate for some pediatric
cancers is as high as 90% but many of
the survivors have a host of health
problems now we have Daniel Clary a
staff writer for science and he's going
to talk to us about a feature he wrote
on fast radio bursts hi Dan alright so
they're fast and they're made of radio
waves what else do we know well very
little actually only about 65 of them
have ever been seen as far as we know
there may be an announcement soon these
were just sort of discovered by accident
and they're very very short you know
they may last a few thousandths of a
second and they're quite bright and
people just thought they were some sort
of error in their detectors at first
because they couldn't figure out what
they were looking closely at the bursts
themselves they soon figured out that
they were not coming from somewhere in
our galaxy so they were coming from deep
deep space and so they must be coming
from something really really bright some
sort of significant event was generating
these things but so far we don't know
what we have the signal what does it
mean yeah exactly so there haven't been
many detected but the ones that show up
over and over again the repeaters are
the ones makes this think this is not an
error in the data this is something else
going on yeah that's right for a long
time there was just one that seemed to
repeat all the others were single events
and they never saw anything else coming
from the same spot on the sky but one of
them repeated again and again and I
think there's been dozens or
even a hundred flashes from that
particular spot but it was the only one
until January this year when a second
one was discovered is that a result of
this new scope that's coming online this
one called chyme yes that's right the
second repeater was one of the first
discoveries made by chyme which is
stands for the Canadian hydrogen
intensity mapping experiment which is in
British Columbia in Canada and is still
in its commissioning phase so it's just
starting to collect data this is not a
big circular dish which maybe some
people are picturing yeah it's an
unusual shape it's four troughs that are
about a hundred meters long and 40
meters wide they don't move they just
look up at the sky and they have lots
and lots of antenna at the focus of each
trough going along on a gantry above
them essentially just looks at a strip
of the sky from one horizon to the other
erasin and it scans the sky because the
earth moves the Earth rotates so over 24
hours it scans all the way around the
northern a sky and does a complete
survey it's very sensitive and got a
wide field view and so it's great for a
survey looking for things that don't
happen very often I noticed that the
acronym chime doesn't have anything to
do with fast radio bursts so is it
looking for both things is it looking a
hydrogen and also looking for a fast
radio bursts it's looking for several
things but what it was originally
proposed it wasn't anything to do with
radio bursts people weren't even looking
for them back then this was you know
about a dozen years ago and they thought
of building this telescope to map out
neutral hydrogen clouds across the
universe if you look at their
distribution you can see ripples from
soon after the Big Bang and if you map
out how those ripples have moved over
the whole history of the universe it
might tell you something about how fast
the universe is expanding and whether
it's accelerating and whether that
acceleration has been constant
and that'll tell you something about
dark energy which is this mysterious
force that people think is accelerating
the expansion of the universe at the
same time while it's doing that mapping
past you can also anytime a fast radio
bursts is in the view it could be
captured by the same instrument exactly
yeah they just are looking at the same
data but just looking at it in different
ways well getting back to the fast radio
bursts you mentioned they're fast and
their major video apes are very bright
they're probably not in our galaxy and
some of them are repeaters what are some
of the theories for a source of the
signal what are some of the ideas that
people have about what could be sending
this out well when people first started
discovering them and they seemed to be
Luna vents people thought they were some
sort of Cataclysm you know something
that just happened once like neutron
star collapsing into a black hole or two
neutron stars colliding with each other
but once they discovered one that
repeated they had to come up with some
other ideas and there are many still
dozens of different theories that are
competing for attention because we don't
even know whether the single ones and
the repeaters are coming from the same
sort of source that could become
different things so there are a lot of
things out there but a lot of them
center around neutron stars because they
know it has to be something very compact
because it's so fast
you can't have a very large object
produce a very fast signal because they
can't within the object they can't send
signals from one side to the other fast
enough to act as one all at once so it
must be something very small about the
size of a city is what they think it's
likely to be something very dense like a
black hole or a neutron star and they
know it's very distant one of the main
candidates are these things called
magnet ours which are a neutron star
that is very very highly magnetic and
that energy here in the magnetic field
causes it to send our blasts of material
that will generate a radio pulse when it
hits other gas clouds nearby so how
would we confirm that it was
that a magnetar one of the ways people
are trying to do that is by narrowing
down where the fast radio bursts are
coming from now usually they're so fast
that telescopes don't have time to focus
in on where exactly in the sky they come
from but the repeater was different
because that meant people could focus
numerous telescopes on the same patch
and wait for it to flash again and then
by combining signals from numerous
telescopes you can identify where it
came from and so the repeater that was
discovered a while ago was narrowed down
to a dwarf galaxy I can't remember how
many billions of miles away but a long
long way away but a dwarf galaxy which
seemed like an unusual type of location
because it's not where you would
typically think the neutron star would
reside but dwarf galaxies do sometimes
produce these things called
superluminous supernova so that's a
supernova that's extra extra bright and
people don't really know what causes
them but perhaps there's some link
between these super bright supernovae
and fast radio bursts Wow so these fast
radio bursts are like the weirdest
things in the universe just pinging us
and saying why don't you look over here
see what you can find
absolutely yeah they're just entirely or
didn't you know it's just getting
theorists and observers in a complete
muddle you know because they just can't
figure out what might be causing them
we're gonna narrow the theories down
probably in the next bit of time as more
and more these signals are read what
what does chime expect to see I mean how
many signals are they expecting to see
when they're actually up and running
because there are so few it's hard to
estimate what the rate is going to be
but their estimates ranged from one or
two a day to maybe two dozen a day and
since we only know of 65 over the past
dozen years of observing that's going to
be a huge increase in numbers if it can
achieve that we're waiting to hear what
exactly they are finding there
preparing some papers at the moment so
hopefully soon we'll see what sort of
bounty they are getting all right do you
have your favorite theory of these 48 or
so that people have proposed for the
source of these well we the sort of fun
outlier is that are they're created by
cosmic strings so these are are sort of
remnants they're almost like a crease in
the fabric of space that some people
think were created very very early in
the universe when it was expanding so
fast that space couldn't really cope and
you ended up with these fault lines that
are still around today again nobody's
seen one but they think they could be
there if you got a kink or a twisted in
one of these it could produce something
like a fast radio bursts oh wow that's
what are those theories that's still out
there and you know the other obvious one
is that some people think they could be
extraterrestrial intelligence is trying
to send us a signal in some way but one
argument against that is that they're
coming from all different directions
across the sky so there would have to be
a lot of different aliens trying to send
two signals by the same methods yeah
alright thank you so much dad okay
Daniel Clara is a staff writer for
science you can find a link to his fast
radio bursts story and a glorious
related graphic at science magnet org
slash podcasts stay tuned for my
interview with Jennifer cousin Frankel
on the long-term effects of pediatric
cancer treatment
[Music]
now we have Jennifer cousin Frankel
she's here to talk about a feature she
wrote as part of a special issue this
week on pediatric cancer the focus of
her article is on the long-term effects
of receiving treatment for cancer as a
child hi Jennifer
hi what made you decide to write about
this particular topic for this special
issue well I've written I'm a lot over
the years about childhood cancer and
I've always been well aware that well
the cure rate for childhood cancer has
has increased over the years and it's
really one of the big successes in
cancer generally there are a lot of
after effects of these treatments were
mainly talking about chemotherapy and
radiation for children and that those
complications can persist for years they
can start many years later and it's a
really difficult problem I actually
wasn't sure if there was really a story
here to write because my sense had
always been that of course we have to
treat these children for their disease
and the treatments are toxic and what
are we going to do about it so I started
to look into that and found that there
actually was a really interesting story
here to tell there's now a population a
sizable population of survivors of
childhood cancers 500,000 I think I saw
in this story and that means that you
can start to really look at what
treatments are doing what over this long
time period yes I should say it's less
than 500,000 but it's it's over 400,000
so it's it keeps increasing with time
because more and more children are
becoming long-term survivors and you
know should get to 500,000 before it too
long what are some of the health effects
that are being seen in the kids that
live through cancer there are a lot of
them and they're also really variable
because of course different kids are
diagnosed with different types of cancer
they need different treatments they're
treated at different ages and so all of
those lead to different health effects
and also to arrange some kids may not
have that many health effects and other
kids may have a lot and I would say some
of the big ones can include cardiac
dysfunction heart problems either
starting soon after treatment or many
years later there can be infertility
there can be
ROI dysfunction there can be a second
cancer that's caused by treatment for
the first cancer
there can be metabolic problems there
can be neurologic problems particularly
for children treated for brain cancer
who got radiation therapy to the brain
that can cause a range of challenges
down the line so it's really variable in
terms of the types of health effects and
their intensity I think most of us know
that cancer therapy can be damaging to
the body but what are some of the
reasons that it's particularly dangerous
for kids well there are a couple of
reasons for that so one of them is just
that kids have a longer time to live so
if you're treating a 65 year old for
cancer and they develop health effects
when they're say 80 that may not be
viewed as the same kind of tragedy as a
child who's treated when they're three
years old and then develops health
effects at 18 and they still have a long
way to go to live their life
that's one reason another is that
children's bodies are different than
adult bodies and on the one hand they
can sometimes withstand higher doses of
certain treatments but at the same time
researchers have found that in some ways
their bodies are more vulnerable to
certain treatments because they are
growing and their tissues are growing
particularly in younger children and
they may be more significantly impacted
their healthy tissues may be more
significantly impacted by the treatment
that's you know of course also killing
cancer cells now that there is a sizable
patient population what kinds of
investigations are being done to figure
out how to remedy some of this how to
keep kids healthy a long time after
they've had cancer so that's something
that was really exciting to me about the
story and I didn't really know going in
how much people were studying this but I
think because there are now so many
survivors and so many doctors have cured
kids of cancer only to see them then
develop health problems and in some
cases die from the after-effects of
treatment and that's that's really
tragic so there actually a lot of
efforts to try and work with survivors
and study them and understand what's
going on one of the biggest and the
oldest is called the childhood cancer
survivor study and that was started in
1990
before to really recruit as many
survivors of childhood cancer as
possible and it now includes more than
25,000 survivors who were diagnosed all
the way back in 1970 until the very late
1990s across the US and Canada and it
also includes a number of siblings who
serve as sort of healthy controls so we
can really compare the effects of
treatment versus no treatment and so
that project has has done a tremendous
amount in you know examining all sorts
of different health effects and
survivors and genetics and just so many
different pieces but then there are
other you know narrower efforts or
smaller efforts to look at smaller
cohorts of survivors or to really focus
on one component of the health problems
that they might have right when you talk
about your story is looking at the
genetic background of different patients
and seeing how vulnerable they'll be to
particular treatments can you talk a
little bit about that yeah so one of the
things that I think doctors have noticed
for a while is that they can have two
kids who have the same form of cancer
they get pretty much the same treatment
and then they have very different
reactions to that treatment long term
and so I spoke with one pediatric
cardiologist who's done a lot of work
with children who later develop heart
problems and he's seen some kids who
thirty years later are doing just fine
in terms of their heart and then he's
seen other patients who thirty years
later have needed a heart transplant or
some of them have died from the cardiac
toxicity of treatment and so you know
really what's going on there something
is separating these different kids from
each other and of course one of the
answers that people gravitate to is
genetics there's something different
about their genetics that may make some
kids especially vulnerable to the toxic
effects of treatment and it could be a
particular toxic effect it could be you
know you're vulnerable just to the
cardiac effects of a certain class of
chemotherapy or just to the effects on
say your hearing because a lot of kids
do do develop hearing loss from
treatment as well so we're talking about
really narrow effects not like an
overall vulnerability but that's
something that people are really
interested in because if we can identify
the kids who were really at risk we may
be able to tailor
treatment or find ways to somehow give
those kids extra protection so that
years later they don't suffer a lot of
complications yeah one other thing I
think we should touch on is this
advanced aging that you discuss in your
story can you talk about some of the
symptoms of that and and what are some
of the mechanisms that are suspected for
causing it yeah so that was some
research that I really found interesting
and unexpected in the course of this
this reporting for the story and we
should clarify you know again we're
talking about a subset of kids a
minority of kids there was a researcher
I spoke with who works at st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital in Memphis
Tennessee she started working there a
little over 10 years ago and she really
wanted to meet a lot of long-term
survivors to try and understand what was
going on and so she set up a sort of lab
to kind of study how they were doing
health-wise basically and they started
to visit this lab and she was really
taken aback because if she said to me
you know they look like old people the
way they walked the way they sort of
carried themselves their muscle strength
there were a lot of details that just
made her think of people who were you
know many decades older than these
survivors were so she and some others
are now investigating that and they are
finding that a subset of kids do seem to
experience a sort of accelerated aging
most likely due to treatment and we
don't know exactly what's going on there
but the thinking is that you know of
course chemotherapy and radiation are
designed to kill cancer cells but we
know that they also damage and kill many
healthy cells as well and one theory is
that when cells are damaged they can
kind of enter this sort of cellular old
age way of being as a way to protect
themselves and expend less energy and
it's possible that those sort of cells
that become aged thanks to cancer
treatment are then communicating with
other cells around them and telling them
to age as well and then they emit
different factors that can cause some
symptoms of accelerated aging but this
is all still pretty early and it's
something that researchers are are
actively studying to try and understand
what's happening and you know ultimately
how to how to prevent it in the kids who
might be affected okay this really you
know you've pointed this out in your
story and I think as we've been talking
this really seems like a tough thing to
do even if you do discover that a child
is at high risk for injury later in life
what is a cancer doctor to do what are
the parents to do how can this kind of
decision be made how are people dealing
with that yeah so again you know we're
really at the beginning of this but it
is coming up it's starting to come up
and one example that was shared with me
was the story of a little boy named
Aysen who lives in British Columbia in
Canada and when he was just over a year
old he was diagnosed with a very
high-risk cancer called high risk
neuroblastoma and he needed a lot of
treatment for that cancer the treatment
he needed included radiation and because
of where the tumor was was sort of in
his chest cavity that radiation was
going to hit his heart and you know
could damage his heart and he also
needed many doses of a particularly
chemotherapy class of chemo therapies
that are known to potentially cause
heart damage and kids the doctors knew
that but they had to treat this child
but then this child was offered genetic
testing which was which was at that
point going on or is going on in a
research setting through that hospital
and the genetic testing found that he
was an extremely extremely high risk of
basically a very severe heart damage
from treatment about almost 90% chance
of severe heart damage according to the
genetic testing and then getting
radiation on top of that would make that
risk even higher and so the doctors were
really very worried about what would
happen to this child
and his parents were worried too and his
parents felt like you know look we can
accept a lot of the side effects of
cancer treatment but this is one that
really feels much less acceptable to us
ultimately after casting around and
trying to find another protocol you know
with another treatment protocol for a
child like this there was one that was
found out of Europe that used just one
dose of the really heart hazardous
chemotherapy and in the end actually in
consultation with an ethicist and of
course the family the doctors left out
that one dose so this was the first time
that this particular piece
a trichologist had treated a patient
like this who had high risk
neuroblastoma without this class of
chemo therapies but they did it it was
scary of course even though he got a lot
of other treatment too but now this
child is in kindergarten he's almost 6
years old he's doing great does not you
know have any cancer and also does not
have any heart damage and so that was a
case where they tried something and it
appears certainly so far to have made a
real difference for that child but it
was you know really really a tough
position for the family and the
physicians to be and as they tried to
figure out what to do it sounds like
this kind of conversation is going to be
happening a lot more too in the future
yeah and I think people are just a lot
more aware of these complications
because the chances of survival are so
much better at least for some of the
pediatric cancers and so people doctors
and families are thinking ahead maybe
more than they used to be able to do and
on the one hand you know they're getting
more information which can be a great
thing but of course it can also be
agonizing as you try and figure out how
to balance the different needs here to
you know help this child as best you can
all right Jennifer thank you so much for
talking with me Thank You Jennifer
cousin Frankel is a staff writer for
science you can find a link to her story
and the related special section on
pediatric cancer at science magnet or
export caste the section includes
reviews on the genomic landscape of
pediatric cancers addressing the gap in
treatment globally and a look at the
progress at targeted therapies for
pediatric cancer and that concludes this
edition of the science podcast if you
have any comments or suggestions for the
show write to us at science podcast at
AAAS so RG you can subscribe to the show
anymore you get your podcasts or you can
listen on the science website that
science Magdeburg slash podcasts to
place an ad on the podcast contact
mid-roll comm the show was produced by
Sarah press P and Meghan Cantwell and
edited by Parvati
Jeffrey cook composed the music on
behalf of science magazine and it's
publisher triple-a s thanks for joining
us